اصيب جنديان اسرائيليان بجروح بين متوسطه
وخطيره في بلده حواره جنوب مدينه نابلس
قالت مصادر اسرائيليه ان سياره مسرعه نفذت
عمليه اطلاق النار وانسحبت من المكان
وتقوم القوات الاسرائيليه حاليا بعمليه
مطارده واسعه لسياره التي استخدمت في
عمليه اطلاق النار فيما افاد شهود عيان
بان القوات الاسرائيليه اغلقت كافه
المداخل والطرقات جنوب مدينتي نابلس
وانضم الينا من رام الله مراسل العربيه
عبد الحفيظ جعوان اهلا بك عبد الحفيظ
بدايه لو تطلعنا على مزيد من التفاصيل حول
هذا الهجوم
الهجوم هو الثالث من نوعه الذي يجري في
غضون شهر في بلده حواره تحديدا الى الجنوب
من مدينه نابلس وقت الافطار تماما سياره
مسرعه كانت تمر من داخل بلده حواره التي
كانت قد تحولت منذ فتره طويله الى سكن
عسكريه فيها تواجد كبير للجنود
الاسرائيليين تقريبا في كل مدخل من مداخل
هذه البلده وبالتالي السياره المسرعه قامت
باطلاق النار بشكل مباشر على الجنود
الاسرائيليين الذين كانوا يتجمهرون عند
احد المداخل في بلده حواره ما ادى الى
اصابه ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين اصابه خطيره
واصابه متوسطه واصابه طفيفه جدا بشظايا
بعدها فرت السياره بشكل سريع من المكان
سرعان ما هرعت الى المكان قوات كبيره من
قوات كبيره اسرائيليه وقامت بملاحقه هذه
السياره بدايه كان هناك شكوك انها فرت الى
بلده بيتا وبالتالي الجيش الاسرائيلي
اقتحم بلده بيتا
يعني تكبير حجم الطوق طوق البحث عن هذه
السياره الان هناك حواجز في مختلف مناطق
جنوب مدينه نابلس هناك اقتحامات كبيره
لبعض الكره والبلدات ومصادرات تسجيل
الكاميرا بلده حواره بشكل عام مغلقه
وتحولت الى تكنه عسكريه مع ايضا قدوم عدد
من المستوطنين الذين بداوا يتظاهرون ايضا
عند
حواره وتاثير ذلك على التفاهمات شرم الشيخ
وايضا على الاوضاع الداخليه في اسرائيل
كيف
يتوقعه المراقبون في اسرائيل وايضا في
الضفه الغربيه
لا شك ان يعني هذا يجري في عكس اتجاه ما
تم الاتفاق عليه في شرم الشيخ وهو اتفاق
التهدئه وان تعمل كلا الاطراف على تهدئه
الامور الميدانيا على الارض ولكن ابراهيم
يعني بالنسبه للجانب الفلسطيني فهم يقولون
ان الجانب الاسرائيلي يعني منذ اليوم
الاول لم يلتزم بهذه التفاهمات في اليوم
الاول من رمضان كان هناك اقتحام لمدينه
طولكرم وقتل شاب فلسطيني البارحه كان هناك
اعلان عن مئات الوحدات الاستيطانيه
وبالتالي يعني مصدر اسرائيل البارحه كان
لافتا ما قال له كان ما قال عن مباحثات
شرم الشيخ قال هي مباحثات امنيه ضروريه
يعني لملا الفراغ وبالتالي لا يبدو ان
هناك الكثير من التعويل على هذه المباحثات
وان كان يعني على الجانب الاخر يمكن رصد
بعض التسهيلات الاسرائيليه ان صح التعبير
بين المزدوجين يعني على موضوع دخول
المصلين الى مدينه القدس ومحاوله عدم يعني
التصعيد تحديدا خلال شهر رمضان ولكن بشكل
عام ابراهيم لا شك ان هذه الامور تؤثر
بشكل مباشر على مباحثات التهدئه البعض
يقول حتى ابراهيم انه يعني اسرائيل ربما
تكون معنيه في بعض العمليات او بعض
الاشياء التي تحدث الامنيه وذلك
لمواجهه التصعيد الداخلي الذي لديها اليوم
كان هناك تظاهرات كبرى في اسرائيل ويوميا
هناك قلق داخلي وتظاهرات داخليه ويعتقد
البعض ان اسرائيل ربما معنيه في الموضوع
الامني وذلك لانه قد يؤثر بشكل مباشر على
تقليل عده التظاهرات الداخليه التي تخرج
في اسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الحفيظ
مراسل العربيه كنت معنا مباشره من رام
الله